exported our jobs treated us like pools
now they're working hard to take over
our schools and run them for profit like
they do our Jail so they make up flies
Miss Anna B fail when the failure is
theirs cuz they stolen our wealth
whatever is good they preserve for
themselves do you think it's good for
the students or bad for the students
that teachers are guaranteed their jobs
for life
first of all teachers are not guaranteed
their jobs for life the way you ask that
question you act like that's a fact
teachers have never been guaranteed
their jobs for life teachers that are
incompetent can always be fired if that
were a fact that would be horrible in
acting there is there isn't job security
right there's an incentive to work hard
and be a better actor because you want
to have a job so why isn't it like that
for teachers you think do you think job
insecurity is what makes me work hard
well you have an incentive to work
harder but if there's job security it's
not an incentive that's the thing so you
take this MBA style thinking right it's
the problem with Ed policy right now
it's just intrinsically paternalistic
view of problems that are much more
complex than that it's like saying a
teacher is going to get lazy when they
have tenure a teacher wants to teach I
mean why else would you take a shitty
salary and really long hours and and and
do that job unless you really love to do
it ever since that our bathrooms ever
since I don't know it's ever sent people
in it
okay but I mean maybe you're a shitty
cameraman I don't know teachers were
fired from Harvard University because of
allegations about that Communist Party
membership that's called the real world
okay not political science seminar
libertarianism 101 that's what happens
and I think that this carried over to
teaching so our first grade teachers
intellectuals that I hope you protected
I hope that they have studied child
development so you're the founder of the
small school movement which promoted a
creativity and choice while own voters
and charter schools do that because the
other were part of a community
Democratic operation precisely what
differentiates me from libertarians at
the same ideal but I also know more
about the corruption of money how much
more would you like to see going to
students how much money do you think a
child is worth it's unconditional
Jordan aren't worth money I mean it
costs $10,000 more than $10,000 per
student right now a million dollars to
raise my children that there's no money
that can be set price on a child's life
and learning so how much so money
it should be about educating our
children on how to survive in today's
world but if you want the government to
spend more how much more per student do
you think should go to education
billions a billion dollar per student
sure why not spending per student has
doubled since 1970 and we're saying that
tests remain the same they've just like
flatlined what do you think the solution
is should we give more money to help
better the school sure we should give us
much money as which people think they
need for their children no cuts no
concessions tax Wall Street JP Morgan is
raping our country gates may be richer
but I am smarter about students I am a
teacher if I stop going to my local
grocery store my local grocery store is
going to be hurt so do you see a problem
with that I don't think education is
exactly this
I'm really sorry education is a basic
social right everyone has a right to a
public education but what about food
isn't food just as important as
education we have we have various kinds
of social safety net to make sure people
can eat that probably doesn't make some
people in this town happy that we have
things like food stamps we have choice
and competition at universities and
preschools so why not K through 12
education private schools in
universities if you're talking about
private universities then that is a
that's a money-making operation right
that is in bed with a capitalistic
system if you're talking about public
schools I don't want that to be
privatized you've written a lot about
poverty in the South Bronx
why aren't vultures and charter schools
an answer to that a vouchers in charter
schools the worst possible answer
because first of all they will never
serve more than two or three percent
maybe five percent at most of the
population so then we need more charter
schools now that's insane
the fact is first of all charter schools
on average are no more successful than
public schools the only ones you hear
about are the super other super schools
the ones that get on Oprah competitions
is winners and losers so if you think
all students poor students kids from
communities that don't have much money
have the same right to a public equality
public education then why do we set them
up to compete with each other why don't
we say all kids need to be having a good
education and and you don't have
medicine that what we're doing right now
don't we have winners and losers now or
all losers right now I don't understand
why you say that we're all losing I mean
you're upset with the current at their
current education system right so aren't
there winners and losers right now I
think the current education system in
the United States has real problems and
most of it is connected to the lack of
equity
four gates to read the achievement gap
hustle is one big crime free